primaires démocrates aux états unis à le
dépouillement total des votes du super
tuesday est pour très bientôt ce que
l'on sait pour l'instant joe biden en
tête dans neuf des 14 états qui ont voté
cette nuit notamment texas seuls des
résultats a dû mais ne sont pas encore
tombés et déception pour elizabeth
warren et michael bloomberg largement
distancé les gens parlent d'une
révolution
on a commencé un mouvement n'a augmenté
la participation la participation a joué
pour nous ça peut nous porter vers un
moment au cours duquel nous pouvons
accomplir des choses extraordinaires
écoutez notre agenda est audacieux il
est progressiste c'est une vision joe
biden a donc à créer la surprise lors de
ce super tuesday cette performance
relance la course à l'investiture
démocrate son portrait tout de suite
allons
m
[Musique]
mais
bernie sanders de son côté a s'est
exprimé face à ses partisans dans le
vermont celui qui se définit comme
socialiste reste très confiant on va
gagner parce que le peuple comprend
notre compagne notre mouvement qui est
le mieux positionné pour battre treuil
et s'il ya un autre candidat dans la
course qui dépensent des centaines et
des centaines de millions de dollars
on va lui dire qu'en amérique on ne peut
pas acheter des élections
[Musique]